PROFESSOR: Today we're going to
finish our discussion of atoms
and light in interaction
and finally get
some of those rates.
Last time, we reviewed
the Einstein's argument.
Einstein used his argument
to discover spontaneous--
stimulated emission
of radiation and how
it accompanies the process
of absorption all the time.
There was also, of
course, this process
of spontaneous radiation
that we found the formula
for that transition rate
in terms of the transition
rate for stimulated radiation.
So let me review a couple
of things that we had.
So we have an electric field
that interacts with the atom.
There's a position vector
that points to the charge, q.
And we have two levels,
level b with energy E b
and level a with energy E a.
We introduce a dipole
moment operator,
which was defined as q times r.
And it's an operator
because r is an operator.
The position is an operator
in quantum mechanics.
So we observe, and we've
observed several times,
that the process is b going
to a of stimulated emission
and the process of a
going to b of absorption
are the same, not
equivalent, the same.
The first order in
perturbation theory, and we
wrote, last time,
the formula for it
using our general formula
for harmonic transitions.
Not firm is golden
rule, because this
was a discrete
transition, apparently,
between these two levels.
So here is the formula.
Let me remind you what it was.
There was an electric field.
It was of the form 2E 0 cosine
omega t times the vector n.
OK.
All our results from the
discussion of light and atoms
from the previous
lecture, so here we go.
The transition probability
as a function of time
is given by this quantity, n
0 is half the peak amplitude
of the electric field.
We always have
this extra 2 here.
d ab are the matrix
elements of the operator d
between the states
here, a and b.
So that's an inner product.
This is dotted with
the vector n that
refers to the polarization
of the electric field.
That half number is squared.
And then we have the sine
squared over x squared function
that we've usually had.
So this is our situation.
But what's going to happen,
what we're interested
and the situation that
Einstein was considering,
was when you had a box,
you had thermal radiation.
And those atoms were there.
Here, we have a discrete
process of transition
from one state to another state.
Neither one is a continuum.
When we had ionization,
we were going
from one state bound to the
continuum of flying electrons.
And therefore, a Fermi golden
rule arose by integration.
Here, what are we to integrate?
Well, there is
something to integrate.
The fact of the
matter is that when
you have this
black-body radiation,
you will have a spectrum,
omega, of electric fields.
You don't just have
one electric field
at one specific frequency.
You will have many components
of the electric field
at different frequencies
at different directions.
So in particular, when you
have a black-body over this,
you will have, in this
spectrum, here is omega ba.
That is the frequency
for which the transitions
tend to be more important.
Remember, when you're
omega, your frequency omega
is the frequency of
the external light.
When your frequency
omega coincides
with the omega of
this transition,
this stimulated emission or
the absorption get enhanced.
So here is omega ba.
That's one of the frequencies
in the black-body of radiation.
But there are many,
many more nearby.
And they are incoherent.
That is, in the
black-body of radiation,
each amplitude for a
different frequency
is independent of
the other ones.
They're, like, random.
So here is our sum, therefore.
We must, we know, that when we
have several inputs, not just
one electric field but
many electric fields,
we will have to add the
transition probability caused
by the different
electric fields.
And in this case,
we will have to sum
the effects of
the electric field
squares of the many components
of the black-body of radiation
that lie near this omega ba.
That is the one that would
trigger a transition.
So this is how we're
going to obtain
something that will look like a
Fermi golden rule as well here.
There is a transition.
The transition is
between discrete states.
But the trigger
for the transition
is a superposition of
electromagnetic waves
that we have to integrate over.
So one can say that the
electric field, electric field
is a superposition of incoherent
waves with different omega i's,
different frequencies,
different E 0 of omega i,
different amplitudes, and
different vectors, unit
vectors.
So each mode of this
black-body radiation
has a different amplitude
and a different omega
and a different polarization.
And we have to sum over
those that are near omega ba.
And we know only over near
ones, because this function
doesn't allow you to--
or it becomes too small
when you get far away
from that central frequency.
So as a first step, I can
rewrite this transition
probability to make
it a little clearer.
I would say, here it is.
The transition probability
for spontaneous emission
of radiation associated
to a particular mode
of the radiation
field would be given
by 4E 0 of omega i
squared, h squared, d ab.
That is some matrix element
of the dipole operator
in the atom.
That doesn't depend
on anything having
to do with the radiation.
n is possibly dependent
on the radiation.
Sine squared of 1/2
omega ba minus omega i.
The omega i is the omega
of the electric field.
So I've put all these things
to represent the contribution
from the ith mode of
the radiation field
to the transition amplitude.
That's what it does.
So you could say,
oh, the ith mode
is one in which I
would write 2E 0 of i.
So here would be 2E 0 of
omega i cosine of omega i t
times the vector n omega i.
That's the ith mode
of the electric field.
And that ith mode of
the electric field,
that's this transition.
And we have to sum
over all these modes
that are nearby here.
OK.
This is one of the
little non-trivial things
that we have to do now.
But the way to think
about it is that we've
seen, from the
Einstein arguments
and in general black-body, that
there is a function u of omega,
which is the energy
density per unit frequency
so that when you
multiply by the omega,
this is the energy
density contained
in the part of the spectrum
with a range d omega.
That's your energy density.
So that's an important
quantity because it
represents a number of photons.
And that's how Einstein
argued that that defines or is
a part of the ingredient
of constructing
the rate at which transitions
would be happening.
So we have to relate
this to energy.
So let's try to
relate it to energy.
So we use things from
electromagnetism,
some basic facts from
electromagnetism.
If you have-- so I'll go here.
If you have a wave,
in general for a wave,
you have an E field
and a B field.
And you have energies u
electric and u magnetic.
These are energy densities.
And there's a simple
formula for them.
The electric energy is
equal to the magnitude
of the electric field
squared over 8 pi.
And in our case, the magnitude
of the electric field
is, the electric field
in our conventions,
is 2E 0 cosine omega t.
So what do we get here?
4E 0 squared cosine
squared omega t over 8 pi.
So this is 1 over 2
pi E 0 squared cosine
squared of omega t.
But nobody really cares about
the fluctuation of the energy.
You need the average
energy at the volume.
So the time dependence
must be averaged.
So from here, the average over
time of the electric field
energy density is the average
over time of cosine squared,
which is 1/2.
So we have 1 over
4 pi E 0 squared.
So that's the average electric
field energy for a wave.
And that's the
average over time.
But in a electromagnetic wave,
the average electric energy
and the average magnetic
energy are the same.
So u M magnetic is equal to u
E. The averages are identical.
And then the total energy
density, therefore, is--
therefore, total u,
it's already average.
Energy density would be u
E plus u M, which is 2u E.
And it's, therefore, 1
over 2 pi E 0 squared.
So our end result is
that the energy density
u is 1 over 2 pi E 0 squared.
OK.
Usually the thing
here that is important
is that there's lots
of factors of 2.
There's factors of 2 in
defining the energy density,
in averaging over
time, in adding
electric and magnetic
contributions up.
This is correct.
It's important to get
those factors of 2 right,
otherwise your final
formulas will be off.
So here is-- the end result
is a nice formula that
allows you to rewrite the
amplitude of your oscillation
in terms of its contribution
to the energy density.
So here it goes.
We can now think
of this by saying,
if I have an electric field
squared at some frequency,
well, that's 2 pi times the
energy density contributing
at that frequency, at just
the specialization of this
to an arbitrary frequency, an
omega i and an omega i here.
So with this, we can now rewrite
this transition amplitude.
The transition amplitude
can be now expressed
in terms of energy densities.
So what do we have?
We have p b to a of t
i would be equal to 4.
That 4 remains there.
And then instead of E 0 squared,
we put 2 pi u of omega i
over h squared.
And not much changes anymore.
The ab n omega i
squared sine squared
of 1/2 omega ba minus
omega i t over omega ba
minus omega i squared.